So I'm going to talk about what is the benefit of using SIFTOM and even combination with
acetylene and venetoclasts in newly diagnosed MPN1 AML.
My disclosures.
So a very important point is related to the responses, how the MPN1 is behaving when the
patients are responding, and what is the influence of venetoclasts in the treatment.
As we already know, in the relapse setting, MPN1 specifically does not impact the duration,
the overall survival, even if MPN1 is mutated versus unmutated.
But the addition of venetoclasts certainly is improving the overall survival, even with
intensive chemotherapy versus no intensive chemotherapy.
This is very likely influenced by the high expression of VCL2 proteins in MPN1 mutated
AML, but there are certainly some challenges.
One of them is that MPN1 many times comes with other mutations, commutations that could
potentially be associated.
So this is a very important point in terms of what is associated with relapse, even if
the patients are treated in the adfront setting with venetoclasts, for which a couple of questions
that I consider relevant.
Can we achieve the cure combining many inhibitors with venetoclasts in the setting of triplets?
And second, how can we come over relapses specifically related to chronic evolution or
secondary AML?
So this slide has been already reviewed by my expert colleagues.
But I just want to point out two questions.
Why is it important to consider many inhibitors in the front line settings?
We already have historically curative options with intensive chemotherapy alone or HMA venetoclasts,
specifically because there is a biological target that makes a lot of sense.
The HOX, MACE, and ONE driven, and that is extremely many independent.
The expression of VCL2, that is highly frequent in patients with MPN1.
And the expression of VCL2, that is highly frequent in patients with MPN1.
That could potentially achieve the deeper remission and durability of responses and
the possibility of cure.
And in the relapsed refractory setting, because there is already data, as my colleagues are
demonstrating, in different many inhibitors when the patient has relapsed disease.
But in newly diagnosed cases, what is ongoing?
I mean, this is a data that my colleague, Dr. Robles, presented in December.
It was one of the co-authors of the study.
This was a study that was presented in 40 patients.
It was a study that was presented in 40 patients where there is results from the phase 1B,
where patients got treatment with monotherapy,
where siftomany, 600 milligrams orally daily,
starting cycle 1, day 8, and then continuously thereafter,
in combination with azacitidine for seven days and venetoplax,
somewhere between 14 to 28 days.
The endpoints were CR and adverse events.
The baseline characteristics, the majority of the patients were,
there is a predominancy of white population, performance status 2 or below 2,
and there were a high proportion of patients with commutations, with FLT3 and IDH mutations.
There were no patients with therapy-related AML.
In terms of the safety, very similar to other many inhibitors,
predominantly two potential points, neutropenias, thrombocytopenias,
talking about cytopenias in those exposed with triplets, followed by sepsis, neutropenic fever,
that was present in a very low proportion of cases.
More importantly, the adverse events associated with many inhibitors related
to QT prolongation of differentiation syndrome were really very low,
3% in each case, and only one showing QT prolongation.
The clinical activities shown here, 86% of the patients responded with overall response rate of 89%.
If we split the responses according to commutations, those with IDH mutations,
had 89% responses versus 77% in those who had commutations with FLT3.
The duration of treatment, and this is on a median follow-up of 26-point weeks,
was not rich.
The median overall survival was not rich.
There were a proportion of MPN1 patients that were able to proceed with transplant,
and 68% of the patients were able to continue to be alive and continue the study.
In conclusion, there were high response rates.
This is a clinical institution study that was presented by Andy Anderson,
combining that with HMA venetoclax, showing similar responses.
There is another study that combined ribomini with HMA venetoclax
that was presented at JCO by Dr. Seiner, where the responses were relatively similar, 85%.
The combination of sistomini with A7 did not result in increased toxicity, as I already showed,
and there is a randomized clinical trial with comment 017.
As part of the key takeaways, I just want to bring some unmet needs
and perhaps questions for my expert colleagues.
First of all, the combination, the triplet, is very effective.
More importantly, there is achievement of MRD, and there is MRD evaluated by NGS,
and MRD with RT-PCR.
The combination is well-tolerated.
There are ongoing phase distress, not only limited to sistomini, but ribomini as a part of the,
HOBON, EVOL2, or sistomini A7 as comment 017.
But there are unmet needs.
Certainly, we need more real-world data, specifically safety, differentiation syndrome,
QT prolongation in regular population, elderly patients.
How to overcome the MEN1 resistant?
How to overcome those cases that already failed venetoclax and continue,
unfortunately, not responding to the treatment?
What is the impact of more deep, ultrasensitive MRD techniques
in treatment decisions?
Specifically, we are considering a patient transplant candidate or no.
And something that I certainly would like the guidance from my colleagues is how
to use this sequentially, you know, what many inhibitor starts first,
and what many inhibitor to start later.
Thank you very much for your time.